salve youtubers e benvenuti ad una nuova
recensione dopo una lunga pausa estiva
che potete notare nei tre punti
principali sudore brufoli e una barba
che manco avessi vissuto su un'isola
deserta
rieccoci qui il film che voglio
recensire oggi e robot rho police a
robot rho police questo film me lo avete
consigliato in tantissimi ma purtroppo
lo conoscevo già film del 2011 scritto e
diretto da christopher sutton avevo
proprio voglia di un buon b movie di
fantascienza perché ne recensisco pochi
quindi questo è robot rho police
il film inizia con una scena in prima
persona in cui possiamo fin da subito
vedere uno dei cattivoni del film
quindi niente mistero niente
preparazione psicologica giustamente se
hai della merda da gettare fi che farlo
subito
e infatti possiamo vedere che la
computer grafica e la classica dei film
di serie b che non è un problema non
quello principale almeno belli però i
titoli di testa
viene fatta vedere una giornalista che
sta facendo un servizio su una cittadina
in cui i robot sono integrati con la
popolazione
roba nuova roba fresca prima venivano
utilizzati esclusivamente come organi
industriali ma poi hanno avuto la
brillante idea di serie leader sociale
wow
il cassiere di una tabaccheria e proprio
futuro che mi ero immaginato portano
l'immondizia accompagnano i bambini
stanno fermi a non fare nulla e il film
che rappresenta il futuro più
verosimilmente di tutti tra l'altro è
utilissimo aver speso miliardi di
dollari per un robot che ti butta la
spazzatura
invece di pagare molto meno una persona
vera a farlo ma quale crisi è crisi è
tutto nella nostra testa viene
intervistato il proprietario dell'amica
ditta produttrice che spiega di voler
portare i robot ovunque black box eppure
non so bene cosa voglia dire mai
inquietante che tenete ferma ferma ferma
ferma un momento perché nel nome di
tutto ciò che è sacro in questa terra
maledetta dovresti costruire dei robot
che stanno in mezzo alla gente con delle
armi da fuoco
qual è la disposizione di pensieri che
ti ha portato ad arrivare ad una
conclusione del genere e come comprarsi
un tostapane che ha un fucile a canne
mozze integrato per che cosa
come ma poi che problema la giornalista
dallo studio le dicono cose appena
successo perché lei non ha visto e la
sua reazione
urla nulla assolutamente nulla
makinen in sistemi che permettono alle
mie spalle un uomo viene trucidato da un
robot
passiamo la linea tom per le previsioni
del tempo si potresti ridirlo però con
un minimo di emozione un minimo e mentre
il robot va via il cadavere rimane lì a
man's chest per l'amor del cielo
qualcuno lo sta portando via gli è
buttata un lenzuolo in faccia
ovviamente il capo dalla camicia viola
non vuole che servizio venga trasmesso
perché altrimenti le vendite dei robot
calerebbero e non sia mai che rimangano
senza cassieri per le tabaccherie una
tragedia
intanto per mettere a posto la
situazione vengono mandati altri due
robot un medico e un poliziotto
bene bravi curiamo il problema con un
altro problema
giustamente che arrestano la cameraman
per qualche motivo
nel frattempo viene intervistato un
esperto di robotica emerge a cena out of
sight europa per forza avete assistito
al primo omicidio che avete messo le
armi da fuoco trogloditi intervistando
un addetto della sicurezza si scoprì che
non è la prima volta che un robot uccide
una persona e nel frattempo la cameraman
arrestata viene uccisa ed altri robot si
attivano
inizia la distruzione di tutto il robot
sono in rivolta e ricomincia a colorado
cafè in tv è davvero la fine del mondo
ma invece di farci vedere qualcosa di
interessante anche che ne so con una
computer grafica abominevole siamo
costretti a sorbirci la telefonata della
giornalista al telegiornale
genova no no no no no no noia
i due protagonisti cercando di salire in
cima ad un palazzo sentono delle urla e
una bambina che scappa da una festa di
compleanno trasformatasi in tragedia
cercano di salvarla ma lei
fortunatamente riesce a scappare
beh la bimba fortunata cosa cioè la
bambina scappa e voi invece di metterla
al sicuro la riportate dentro ed infatti
vengono attaccati da robot complimenti
per fortuna vengono aiutati dal loro
capo e riescono a batterlo lanciandogli
addosso una giacca
ma è ovvio come se i robot avessero
degli occhi umani
mica che esso un visore termico o dei
sensori di prossimità ma che la prossima
volta potete cercare di addormentarlo
con il cloroformio o facendogli la presa
vulcaniana ma la bambina che era stata
lasciata da sola in un palazzo pieno di
robot assassini è sparita ma va ma che
strano
ciao io sono d'ora in questa scena c'è
un idiota del cazzo ma non riesco a
trovarlo
puoi aiutarmi bravissimo hai trovato
l'idiota del cazzo alla prossima
avventura
ciao quindi continuano a salire perché
in cima c'è un elicottero ma magicamente
si ritrovano fuori dall'edificio e
l'elicottero precipita chissenefrega
andiamo avanti tutti e tre feriti ed
impauriti vedono dei robot spuntare
dalla strada e cosa decidono di fare
fermarsi proprio lì a girare un servizio
ciao io sono a dare lo so lo so
idioti del cazzo vedete è questo che
accade per tutto il film i protagonisti
agiscono in maniera completamente priva
di senso sempre scappando finiscono in
una foresta in cui ci sono degli enormi
tubi con dentro dei sopravvissuti e
vengono inseguiti da dei robot a quattro
zampe
ma porca ma non riesco neanche a
descrivervi decentemente cosa succede
perché tutta lo va a casaccio
sembra che abbiano scritto la
sceneggiatura usando la palla magica
delle risposte allora scrivi e tubi fu
netta scende a caso quattro zampe
il cameraman viene catturato ed ucciso
da un robot nascosto nelle frasche
parlo lo sforzo e mezzo predator ma ce
la faranno i nostri eroi a salvarsi
spero di no si scopre che la rivolta è
stata fatta scoppiare dall amico del
proprietario della megaditta perché i
robot li avevano progettati insieme ma
solo lui si era preso tutti i meriti
giocato meno
adesso sai cosa faccio uccido tutti così
impari
non potrebbe esserci un pretesto più
stupido e banale di questo qui intanto
un ragazzo vestito da militare salva
tutti facendo esplodere i cani bot con
delle granate esplosioni ragazzo
asiatico
gli regalano ai granata e va via
mi correggo questo non prete fa ancora
peggiore di quello prima non potevano
scrivere un altro modo per far trovare
ai protagonisti un'arma invece di far
apparire e scomparire un personaggio
totalmente inutile in 20 secondi
comunque i due scappano e si ritrovano
dentro dei tunnel
il tizio per salvare la ragazza e farla
scappare decide di sacrificarsi o un
comportamento quasi umano
sono commosso infatti si fa inseguire
dai cani e raggiunge di nuovo la ragazza
brutto schifoso decerebrato
rincoglionito allora cosa è servito
dividersi ma soprattutto perché perdo
un'ora e mezza della mia vita per vedere
queste boiate sono ormai bloccati quando
si vede il direttore che insieme ad un
tecnico riescono a capire come fermare i
robot premono un tasto e
questo non lo accetto dopo tutto lo
schifo che mi hai tirato addosso
pretendo pretendo un finale ma farlo a
finire così senza nessuna spiegazione e
senza dargli il ben che minimo
combattimento finale
no proprio no questo film è una tragedia
molti lo hanno difeso dicendo che è
stato fatto con pochi soldi stronzate il
fatto di avere poco budget non implica
il dover scrivere una sceneggiatura
senza né capo né coda
questa è mancanza di talento
posso benissimo passare sopra gli
effetti speciali e la recitazione ma
quando mi propini roba del genere ti
saluto exchange